[Music]
and never to old news to do all over 200
oh my god thinking that [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] you guys inception in that never
Luther Luther Vandross submitted by
warrior of John Mallia oh you better be
a good one us you're gonna die a 63 year
old woman uses pole dancing to stay
young I don't want to see no grandma
stripper but should pay for drama it's
such a [ __ ] skill it's [ __ ] hard
good I love pole dancing all right
awesome I know you're a dude like guys
are really good on the poles no mana
dude
upper body strength did that graceful
like a girl knew her or not I
accidentally I accidentally clicked this
guilt porno and it was a grandma being
[ __ ] and I was like so disgusted I
just turned off my phone and I did I
couldn't even finish jacking off how did
you accidentally click on it you're just
looking at the thumbnail size positive
oh yeah yeah she's fine
they're like it was like you they called
her a milk they should have called her a
[ __ ] girl because she was like you
were looking for milk porn you fun you
think this [ __ ] looked hot or my fault
he's avoiding the question
I like all kinds okay look it's like I'm
here to have a little pork a little bit
of beef that's all it's not some milk
that's hot it's like I thought she was
hot could I just saw one butt cheek or
something but then I could tell like
what do the seeder citizens like me what
the hell man Oh ass I said you like all
porn no not that kind I should sets the
crazy side
whenever I hear a horn like that like
mill skill incest all that [ __ ] like
what part of that is appealing is I
don't think I'd be out of it
I'm just looking at I don't think people
are reading the times I don't read it of
it it's what's on this summer thumbnail
and they just click it goes not a title
yeah I can't get click baited you just
turn off the homepage or maybe they read
the time like brother [ __ ] sister
girl huh but they still click it because
they're not the enemy there's no they're
not brother and sister but so but the
guilting is hard to work around though
that's just a grandma it's just a
grandma with a little popcorn hair and I
start smelling the ball position before
like been make it here that the big
saliva oh you just waiting for a [ __ ]
this is a dandy down ha ha ha granny
with no teeth nope maybe every beat
lemak I don't give a [ __ ] in the grandma
oh you want to get eaten oh my grandma's
in there now I don't have a penis I'm
thinking about the Phoenix England no
teeth I can't even feel like people who
are into like that type of perversion is
because they've masturbated so much to
the regular [ __ ] they need something
really different you know like okay or
they have grandma issues like if you
don't watch porn for a long time and
then you watch porn again after like
let's say eight or a month or a year
yeah it's like you got version I and it
could be kind of you just salt you
already saw it but it's brand-new I I
know I know that I know I know yeah you
just don't watch it for very long no and
it it's like eyes are so version like
this is just vanilla sex like what the
[ __ ] why am I getting so turn on it is
actually like two days of no guys just
regular missionary and I'm like wow it's
like the [ __ ] porn
I know exactly but that's what people
were talking about how sometimes like
porn ruined sex you know because you had
this certain set idea of what sex should
be through this like imaginary bath oh I
got it so God just like excuse me baby
not screaming and I'm [ __ ] you I'm
the opposite I look at that I'm like
you're acting change that's not real I
think
most girls watch it I feel like we know
when it's fake more like oh come on
turn down the [ __ ] of volume you're so
fake that's what I don't like the high
production site raising up their ending
sit down I'll see at all like I just
don't like it at all
even like when the moaning could you
know it's so big - yeah you got to stop
watching the high production ones and
you just got to watch the ones where
couples record it and if you have a
good-looking couple and the angry like
angle bro my camera movement it was they
do it on the webcam and all that you
feel the passion between the two and you
just like these she's sucking his dick
like it's [ __ ] the breath of life
that's that there's a difference between
legs she's she's [ __ ] riding that
dick with real passion versus she's
trying to perform as a performing artist
I think I'm a sucker because I liked
angles I like actually good lighting
yeah you want HD porn I just don't like
it when it's like like [ __ ] waiters
yeah
well I thought you maybe you want like
4k porn it has all this noise because I
so the lighting is so [ __ ] up well
anyway just talking about this yeah how
do we get the porn Matthew has grandma
you put it up the guilt [ __ ] I know
it's like [ __ ] a raisin goddamn so
this is Lynn she is 63 years old from
Australia what is she a [ __ ] retired
genie she looks good remember that TV
show genie in a bottle oh yeah I do much
she made a total of 16 eggs [ __ ] saw
glaring Ruffalo I'm Seri in a bottle
isn't got a boatman oh yeah that's why
she was awesome yeah she was actually
very racy for a time because she was
showing her belly button yeah it was
like it was like some new shirt even she
has her belly button cover yep with that
Biebs
I had me anal beads she's not a racy
love that my chariot she
taking full attention when she was 56
years old and this was beckoned don't
show me one with split Russian hurts so
much she strongly pretty good yeah I've
tried that stuff and when you're
spinning around it hurts your skin like
how do they how do I battle that I mean
do you try it
remember a friend house has it in the
living room I'm spinning around on it a
half month you should post it touch your
skin make a whole bunch of burns you
should don't they put like Vaseline and
that's why there's been a stripper
battling no whole girl the strippers
they put [ __ ] powder all over from
head to toe and it's like a thick coat
of it I don't know about that I mean it
could be maybe they're burning of chalk
because like you know what people like
with a good chocolate mix though yes
that would rip your skin off just like
stripper does it's like foundation and
[ __ ]
holy [ __ ] yeah so this is not on a
school dance no so this is actually the
answer 60th birthday party so she needed
a goal for herself to try to do a
performance for her family in Prague
okay I'm okay grandma you want to see
grandma became five six years organizing
like holy [ __ ] never party she did
pretty good shape though strong as you
saying that she wants to do another
performance for seven years
you know there's a very similar sport
that's a little bit less a little bit
more acceptable like she could get into
pull-ups you know like when they do the
bar star stuff like Palestine this is an
acceptable thing it's just a little bit
too freaky like she can be doing you
know the whole body you know the stuff
where they're like pretend like they're
stepping up and they go into the
pull-ups they go like this and they go
like that it's not as great more all
this is more dancing you know what's so
funny about them guys this one's like
this we'll say psych you know what if I
don't want to something to make I'm cool
with it but a grab off on a ball
it's because they're already branded I
don't want to change their branding
who's they the grandma yeah my daughter
I shut the [ __ ] orders Brandon oh
whatever she want shut up it's in your
mouth no if I could imagine you turn
your life maybe that's a good luck
Sheree car and then now you want to turn
that into like an off-road vehicle it's
like you already have the sentimental
value to this car you don't want to
destroy it but if you're building a car
from scratch you could have any purpose
you wanna [ __ ] up make any sense I think
I think I think a child has more
sentimental value they have more
innocent no.30 custom battle you haven't
put anything into them yet these never
put anything no I'm talking about you're
customizing another deeper hole that is
mine okay just all the toys you know I
know you want a real artist whether your
fighter do you want to be glad academics
we celebrated fathers difference that
was just need to get cut like [ __ ]
cutting him a boner and customizing the
kid does not have any access to this
child the ground all you guys there your
grandmother charge of all you guys that
the grandmas a finished product and now
you're changing with responding at sixty
years old they don't have tears in them
all right and hopefully not so if I was
her husband and this is your husband
finally say what does he do a top down
five or some [ __ ] my big still works I
could bust dinner all day long everybody
view the tap dancer like whoa look at
all those tappings it's not tapping as
my knees popping okay that's pretty cool
though because it's keeping her fit yeah
she looks great yeah when most people
are complaining about I'm too old to
that my cankles [ __ ] up yeah it's
exactly what she was saying like since
you've been pulled dancing it's like
really alleviating on her aging problems
right she's upside down all the time
that's why I hate antigravity treatment
that's good it's just decompressing
respond yes or even a great-grandma
so she likes that look how about happy
happy that baby that maybe is cute
that baby got a big smile she makes me
fishing you can like I know I can
started at 56 I know I'm not saying I
can't I'm not saying I don't have the
ability I'm saying hey look what I'm
saying I ain't being acted not really I
thought you liked being a friend I like
being athletic at the things that I like
though so if I could play exactly ball
and also somehow build enormous muscle I
don't know who can love that you don't
even but really good if you really do
and all it does is to cardiovascular
yeah I just know like you have to the
switch actually I'm happy that the
ground was making grandpa horny because
if I was how do you know he's making him
horn off or I she's doing it for itself
if I was grandpa and then my wife was
starting to pole dance and I'm like damn
when I thought that I have to go bang
23 year old hookers at 65 years old you
are putting effort and you're making my
dick live again without Viagra thank you
so much it's like you're changing the
game for me hope you guys enjoyed that
video but if you didn't guess what you
can directly contribute to the articles
that we discussed just cruise on over to
the description box below click on that
link to submit your article also for the
next video click right up hey
you
[Music]